hey guys Nikita and I was just at a fuel
station filled up the car
and there was someone there and we
started the conversation with him and I
asked him do you love Jesus Christ and
he shared with us something terrible
that just happened to him and that he's
struggling with something and that's his
two kids the one is in the hospital the
other one was just attacked hand cut off
and the tears started to flow and we
talked to him a little bit and
I felt that the Holy Spirit led us to be
there at this time for this person who
is also called Daniel
so I want to remind you to not just be
so self-absorbing in your own bubble
there are people out there that need
your light
you need to share the gospel be the
light and listen to the holy spirit so
that when people need you need God but
God working through you then you are
there for them love other people as you
love yourself